john mccain says that he will vote for
tax reform what a chilly day in hell
Nancy Pelosi is called on the
longest-serving member of Congress from
her own party to resign and The Daily
Show mocks senator Lyle Wafaa Elizabeth
Warren and calls Trump woke did
Christmas come early we will analyze
alongside our award-winning panel of
deplorable --zz Jason Russell of the
Washington Examiner and Vincent Buda of
live from Studio 6b plus speaking of
Christmas
we will talk to author Leo Severino
about his new book going deeper a
reasoned exploration of God and truth
then all of your questions will be
answered in the mailbag I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael anole show
[Music]
so much to talk about today there is so
much good cafe stuff going on before we
can talk about it though we have to
remember the reason for the season
before we open our Christmas presents of
tax cuts and weird sex stuff
and Democrats eating their own we have
to remember that Christmas isn't about
presents it's about God and in that
spirit we bring on author Leo Severino
to talk about his new book going deeper
a reasoned exploration of God and truth
Leo thank you for being here you like me
or a decadent gaudy st. venerating
papist your book presents a number of
clearly laid out arguments for the
existence of God and his nature largely
drawing on st. Thomas Aquinas I have
actually been referring to the book
around the office as the Summa
Theologica because it some of it you
know it's not the whole encyclopedia of
Theologica but it is an excellent you
know
concise edition and it offers a concise
taste of Aquinas so my first question is
why did you write this book and why did
you write it now well first of all thank
you for being such a venerable company
is same time sequoias and michael
knowles I appreciate star studded hall
of fame I've been added to it thank you
so much my problem the reason I wrote
the book was essentially it was very
personal because it was kind of my
journey from the result of being part of
the university system that was rooted in
our modern philosophy through a more
realistic approach to to life in
philosophy so it was really good article
me just kind of put out my experts kind
of logically being logically mentally
girls up I decide I got college kids now
they seem to think that philosophy began
with Descartes and they don't even
really get him or any of his
contemporaries but they don't understand
that the human search for knowledge and
meaning and God and their own nature
goes back a little further than 300
years so youth you felt that on campus
this was a there was this dearth of
wisdom and yes so what led you to these
the arguments you make in the book well
I was part of that I mean I only realize
much later that philosophy kind of ended
with a part but didn't really start with
it but
no I I can't cast aspersion because I
was part of that world I studied
philosophy and I was quite after that
equipment good at it and by that I met I
was quite good at putting up such silly
notions as there is no truth as if that
were true that's what I thought
right and so I was really submissiveness
for them for a very long time took me
actually through law school before I
started realizing that there was a whole
world prior 300 years ago that actually
something is very clear that evolution
where you finally hit and you realize oh
you know the statement there is no truth
is a self-defeating statement because
obviously if there is no truth and that
includes the statement there is no truth
and you end up with nothing you and you
begin the book with that argument and
you lead into another a number of other
arguments the unmoved mover the argument
from Thalia teleology also all excellent
compelling arguments I think for a lot
of people who were steeped in modern
philosophy and I've never heard these
things it will give you a good rational
basis for God and the existence of God
but I remember reading I think it was in
Jesus of Nazareth and the infancy
narratives by Pope Benedict Pope
emeritus Benedict the 16th that he
doesn't believe that people can come to
belief in God through arguments I always
convinced myself that I was first
brought to believe in God through
arguments but I'm not so sure he
believes that there has to be a base
level of faith that that God has to
approach you before you can reach back
to him did you find that to be the case
or do you think that right now for this
rationalist materialist culture the way
that we can bring people to God is
primarily through these arguments what I
tend to decide what simple and as much
as he says that God can be many things
that were created and I think it's
actually putting pretty close to a
tendon to say that we can't know God but
she might lose that I think back to the
council of florence and a couple other
places that was set forth what I find to
be compelling to me is this it either it
is or isn't and if it is at some level
even if we obviously can't know full
depth of
inner workings of the Holy Trinity that
God isn't open think of something that
could be produced and does my attempt
but you know one of my favorite
arguments that you didn't include in the
book but I really like it it's one that
really convinced me is the ontological
argument which in a nutshell there are
much more elegant versions of it but in
a nutshell it's God is the maximally
great being and if he had if he's
maximally great it's better to exist but
not to exist
so therefore God exists and it it
doesn't convince a lot of people I find
it lovely I really enjoy that argument
is there something about these arguments
that is so whimsical that that that
speaks to the character of God himself
and the character of the world that we
see or is it all just logical drudgery
I had a closer he's since passed his
name was Alan Dallas Willard at USC and
he was a seal and he always told Leo if
you can't explain it to you and anything
like that and it let's just say suppose
it was Scott you know if you can't
explain that mother you don't know it's
it's rich and I think the see is that
there's there's not a truth and I think
they're two sides and when we know
something there's a beauty to it
symmetry wasn't cleared by just about
anybody
that's absolutely right there's truth
and beauty and that's all we know on
earth and all we need to know and they
clearly have a relation to one another
so if you are ignorant about these
arguments for God which I think a lot of
people are go out this is a really clear
book it's really concise you can read it
quickly it is that this isn't you know
an 800 page tome it's really a nice
overview of these arguments for God I'm
certain that you'll be convinced if you
take the argument seriously enough and
so go check it out it's going deeper a
reasoned exploration of God and truth by
Leo Severino leo thank you for being
here good to have you and it will have
to have you back thanks okay before we
bring on our panel before we do that
we've got a we got to pay for our
Christmas presents we don't just get to
present all of our Christmas present
like John McCain giving his tax cuts and
and all the weird sex stuff on the
Democratic side we we got to pay for
that folks this is capitalism so we need
to first talk about helix sleep helix
sleep the one thing I really love about
these guys is they keep the lights on
the other thing I really love about them
is they make easy one of the most
frustrating and difficult experiences
that people every few years have to deal
with and that's shopping for a mattress
I've moved around a little bit from
Connecticut in New York LA I always have
to get a new mattress you know the
stores make it's pretty difficult you
can never get one that's really
custom-made for you they all mark up the
prices and they use different names so
you never you can't really compare costs
it's a it's a frustrating endeavor helix
sleep solves all of those problems so
you know there are a ton of online
mattress retailers they're popping up
all over the place
what makes helix the best well all those
other ones they have a one-size-fits-all
solution to a better sleep but guess
what
one size does not fit all I I won't tell
any tales out of school but sharing a
bed with my fiance we have different
preferences on the bed some I like it a
little harder she likes it a little
softer
she likes to rip all the covers off it
gets very messy he likes sleep offers
something that doesn't exist anywhere
else a mattress that's personalized to
your unique preferences and sleeping
style that won't set you back thousands
of dollars so if you go to helix sleep
comm slash Knowles
that's Keo wles like who like Beyonce
take their simple two to three minutes
sleep quiz they will build you a custom
mattress that will be the best thing
you've ever sleep done I hate spending
time filling out questionnaires and
things I will not spend more than five
minutes this will take half that time
just two to three minutes trust me you
spend a third of your life sleeping I
spend about two thirds of my life
sleeping it really matters what you're
sleeping on make sure that you get
something good for couples they'll even
personalize each side of the mattress
everyone is talking about it from GQ to
Cosmo to the New York Times they're
talking about helix and once you try it
out you will know why it might be the
first true story the New York Times was
published in a while your custom
mattress arrives direct to your door in
a week shipping is completely free how
long can you try it for 100 nights if
you don't love it they will pick it up
and refund you in full so go to helix
sleep duck
/ Knowles right now while you're there
maybe you get the mattress protector
maybe you get the foundation I don't
know give it a look definitely give
these mattresses a look Hilux sleep calm
/ Knowles you will get 50 dollars toward
your custom mattress that's just for my
listeners that's just for a little extra
comfy fake Christmas present Hilux sleep
calm / Knowles $50 off your order Hilux
sleep calm / what Marshall oh you nailed
it right there that's why we keep them
around
all right thanks to Hilux sleep now we
have let's get to the presents let's
open up the presents baby it is
Christmas time in November we have to
bring on the panel we have Jason Russell
from the Washington Examiner and Vincent
Buda of live from Studio 6b gentlemen
thank you for being here let's get right
into it it is a chilly day in hell
Senator John McCain tweets quote after
careful consideration I have decided to
support the Senate tax reform bill
though not perfect this bill will
deliver much-needed reform to our tax
code grow the economy and provide long
overdue tax relief for American families
I'm just gonna let's just have a moment
let's try to process this without our
brains frying up Vincent is this
possible is he going to pull the rug out
from under us or are we going to get tax
reform well I say thank you John McCain
finally come into your senses but you
know this guy's hatred for Trump has
just gone way too far
it's like listen the topic that we're
talking about right now is we're so
happy and surprised he's actually gone
along with it right something he's run
on something the whole party believes in
and we're like oh thank you John McCain
this is what he should do not let his
personal hatred of Donald Trump change
how he votes on things or or policy you
know so you know for me it's very
frustrating I'm like okay great thank
you John McCain hallelujah it is
Christmas I know I didn't think I would
be saying that phrase before the end of
the year but thanks John McCain as long
as you follow through Jason Marco Rubio
and Mike Lee have proposed an amendment
to this tax reform bill to raise the
corporate tax rate from 20% to 22% in
exchange for higher child care credits
since when is it up to conservative
since when is it the conservative
opinion that a 20% corporate tax rate is
too low
yeah it's a pretty interesting amendment
they have and I think it's an
interesting conservative debate about
whether you want to increase the you
know child tax credit as a result of
that I don't personally think it's a
great idea you know I would rather see
the that corporate tax rate stay at 20%
and then that the child tax credit stay
at the current rate that it is at the
proposal so you know I hopefully this
doesn't blow up the whole thing you know
I say put up for vote and if it gets
enough 50 votes and they say go for it
then fine you know I still think that
even if that is included it's still a
better build in the status quo and I
hope that Mike Lee and Marco Rubio agree
I hope even if this amendment doesn't
get included that they would still vote
for tax reform because this is much
better than the status quo including in
terms of the child tax credit mm-hmm and
I'm actually just confused about why
Mike Lee would put his name on this
I understand little Marco might want to
get a little squishy he's the favorite
conservative of every conservative who
lives surrounded by liberals but Mike
Lee is a pretty rock-ribbed guy it's
hard to get more right-wing and
conservative than him
Vincent why is Mike Lee on board with
this oh boy I say that's a great
question because it's shocking to me
that Mike Lee is on board with that
overall so I don't really know why he's
doing this the only things I could
surmise is that many Republicans and we
have seen this particularly in the last
year seem to be some somewhat scared of
the Democrats and what they may want so
they try to proactively react so they
can get things through but while they
control everything that you know the
house and the Senate so you have
Republicans like Rubio and now Lee I
think reacting to those things you know
listen as here as your other guest just
said I agree even with this it's still a
better deal so I'll take that but Mike
Lee this is really strange unless he's
feeling some pressure from you know
voters in his neck of the woods that are
on the left and thinking we got to do
something more with child care credits
and that got a trouble it's very easy
for me because all I have to do is talk
to this microphone and look into the
camera it's very easy for me to say we
should have a 15 percent corporate tax
rate and it doesn't matter
we need to increase the child tax credit
but I don't have to answer to
constituents these guys do it's a it's a
much harder TV ad when it says Mike Lee
voted for corporations instead of giving
your children some extra money or
whatever I do understand that that said
I don't know he's a rock ripped guy and
I'm just surprised at him and I wish
that we could be more rock-ribbed about
this I was pushing for that 15 percent
corporate tax rate but sure I'll take
what I can get especially if John
McCain's on board it's a lot harder to
make the sausage than it is to go
criticize and look at the sausage
factory Jason one aspect of this that
has gotten a lot of attention is
graduate students so for an tuition
right now graduate students do not have
to pay income tax on their tuition
credits let's say the grad school pays
them 20 grand a year in stipends they
also pay them 30 grand a year as tuition
but you never see that they just keep
the money and it's a matter of
accounting now their taxable income
could go to that full $50,000 my fiance
is a graduate student I could be
personally negatively affected by this
but that said who cares
there was a walkout yesterday among
graduate students and there's a big
national protest the big walkout what
they misunderstand is that for a walkout
to work you have to provide a service so
there has to be a demand for your
service or there's no service being
provided they can just keep on walking
do you think that we ought to rectify
this aspect of the tax proposal or
should we let the universities sort it
out and let the grad students pay a
little more yeah I could see this either
way and in my personal opinion III can
kind of I saw I saw it a little bit with
the graduate students on this one and
that's because again like you said this
is kind of an accounting thing the
universities don't actually give this
money to the students they just keep it
basically and say well we'll take money
off of your tuition and the cost of that
right so it's not it doesn't really seem
like income it's basically just saying
the university's saying well we're gonna
give you this service for free instead
of paying for you to then just give it
straight back to us you know this is
pretty expensive
it's an
kind donation at least right shouldn't
it be regulated as such yeah yeah and so
I concede it away like I said but you
know again it's it's not a huge deal to
me and it comes to that walkout thing
you know I don't see how that's gonna be
effective you know maybe that makes some
noise on your college campus but you
know the members of Congress are not on
your college campus they're here in DC
so how they expect to make a big stink
where they walk out on their own college
campuses that no one in DC or in
Congress is gonna notice I don't know
and as you point out this is a matter of
accounting if the the universities
aren't going to lose all of their
consumers all of their customers they're
not gonna let it happen so they'll
probably just account for tuition in a
different way and get around all of this
but as a as a matter the the American
campuses have been in crisis for decades
for 40 years Allan bloom wrote it
expertly in the closing of the American
mind there's a crisis not only of the
institution but of liberal education
generally these crazy fields of study
they usually end in Studies Harold Bloom
the great literary critic referred to it
as the school of resentment it isn't a
serious engagement with scholarship it's
a basically political activism
masquerading as scholarship as the left
frequently does it hollows out great
institutions and then they just become
zombie institutions for their political
agendas it doesn't seem to me that we
need as many graduate students as we
have I seems to me Wes specially when I
talk to my friends Millennials who have
a ton of student debt very few career
prospects in the any Academy it's
virtually impossible to get a job it
seems to me not a terrible thing that we
would maybe disincentivize or stop
subsidizing people from following this
path it doesn't seem like a great path
for a lot of them and for those who are
the elite of the elite in the
intellectual elite they'll find the
money the universities will account for
it I think and they can find outside
funding as well
i does not seem to me that we should be
the solution to this awful crisis of
intellect and of scholarship over the
last 40 years it doesn't seem to me that
we will be correcting it by continuing
to subsidize the perpetrators but that's
just me i'm sure i'm gonna get a lot of
hate mail from my millennial pals after
saying that let's move on to more news
let's move on we have
the debt you're not gonna believe this
one hold your breath if you've had any
hot drinks please spit it out now or
swallow the Democrats are holding their
own accountable for their weird sex
crimes this we didn't expect this either
but here is Nancy Pelosi explaining the
issue with John Conyers the allegations
against congressman Conyers as we have
learned more since Sunday are serious
disappoint disappointing and very
credible it's very sad
the brave women have came forward or
owed justice I pray for congressman
Conyers and his family and wish them
well
however congressman Conyers should
resign as dean congressman Conyers has
served at Congress for more than five
decades and shaped some of the most
consequential legislation of the last
half century however zero tolerance
means consequences for everyone no
matter how great the legacy it's no
license to harass or a discriminate
there is a lot to dissect in that
statement John Conyers by the way is the
Dean of the House of Representatives he
is the longest-serving representative in
Congress he's a Democrat he's been
around since the Johnson administration
he's been serving since the 1960s
Vincent why are they willing to throw
John Conyers under the bus but not Al
Franken oh my goodness you know this
whole first of all Nancy Pelosi goes on
Meet the Press and she doesn't have a
big issue with it she's saying well they
need to investigate it and I don't I
don't know I don't know the women who
said this do I believe them or not I
don't know she had all these defensive
things to say because there was no
chance that she was gonna support this
or trying to have him removed or anybody
else removed because there you know they
seem to just all be like a flock of
sheep following each other blindly then
she gets pressure put on her from those
comments from Meet the Press which even
people on the Left were appalled by one
thing that people don't talk about with
this whole situation he he paid someone
off you know he used monies to silence
someone that accused him of something
that's you know admitting guilt it's not
just a couple of women coming out and
saying he groped or did this and this
and that which I didn't know that's
there were payoffs absolutely
that's what drives me crazy Jason is is
Al Franken next is are they gonna let
these other guys fall or is Conyers just
the old dessicated no longer politically
useful corpse of the sacrificial lamb
yeah I think it's Franken hasn't been
thrown under the bus yet because he's a
little bit more prominent one as a
senator but two because he's famous Al
Franken everyone knows him from Saturday
Night Live he's the funny man in the
Senate he's good enough he's smart
enough and god doggone it Democrats like
him yeah yes against him continued to
grow which I think they probably will
then I expect he at some point they will
start to say yes Franken has to go as
well you know there's just really no
excuse for the kind of behavior that
he's been doing I don't know you're more
optimistic than me I think you give them
more credit than I do
I think Conyers is about a hundred and
fifty years old and useless and they can
toss him under the bus and not sacrifice
their younger more promising talent but
maybe I'm just a little cynical I don't
know let's get two years let's get to
think about that yeah yeah let's get to
this wonderful clip this might have been
my favorite clip of all from The Daily
Show Trevor Noah
called Donald Trump woke and he slammed
Elizabeth Lyle wathah Warren here's the
clip I don't think Donald Trump was
actually trying to offend those Native
American War veterans and I was crazy to
say it but he doesn't care about them he
saw an opportunity to feud with
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
because he's been calling her Pocahontas
long before he met with these heroes you
might be thinking wait Trevor I'm
confused is Elizabeth Warren Native
American and you see that's the question
but in his own way he's hitting
Elizabeth Warren for saying she was
Native American when she wasn't
something she's never apologized for or
owned up to so as weird as it is to say
in his own racially offensive way Donald
Trump was being woke yeah and that's
unfortunately the truth and like a
Bernie Sanders pop album the truth isn't
always something we want to hear
unbelievable every late-night show every
single one I think there are now 750
across network and cable they are all
left-wing every single one of them all
they do is make Trump jokes Stephen
Colbert would have been canceled if not
for Donald Trump it gave him a new surge
but all of these guys put together get
not very many more viewers than in the
old days Jay Leno used to get just by
himself Jay Leno was a much more Middle
America even keel not that political
comedian is this a sign Vincent the
comedians are finally realizing that
maybe they shouldn't uh Turley ignore
and mock half of the country or is it
just the case that Elizabeth Warren is
such a joke they couldn't resist making
how long can they continue the hypocrisy
is really my question you know I used to
like Trevor Noah too but I but like
Stephen Colbert and others it's all hate
comedy but he's right you know if you
think about how Donald Trump operates he
points out hypocrisy and that's what he
was pointing out and these late-night
comedians would I don't understand
here's my big question they're
alienating 50% of the audience every
time they pull one of these hate jokes
they use now the fact that Trevor Noah
actually came out and said something
truthful you didn't hear the audience
respond by the way did see all those out
here a pin drop oh my goodness I
couldn't believe it if this was anything
bad against Trump it would have been a
standing ovation and the wave would have
been done you know actually I didn't put
it in that hypocrisy but he had he did
say prefaced his comments where he said
basically Trump is right about this and
alizarin is despicable for pretending to
be a Native American he had to preface
it by saying look look I think Trump is
racist in everything and then they
started moving and hooing and cheering
but that was just for fun tree he had to
do it or they would have stormed out
Jason his Trump permanently branded Liz
Warren as a fraud as a deceiver you know
little Marco low-energy jeb lyin Ted the
OHS things stuck like glue does she have
a chance in 2020 if she is just forever
Pocahontas I don't think she has a
chance of 2020 but I don't think it's
because
Bernie Sanders again but you know this
time it's a slightly different yeah less
funny that's funny
less interesting to watch give speeches
things like that I don't think she has a
chance because of that she's just not
very fun to watch not doesn't quit great
speeches and most of all does not
connect with ordinary Americans in
middle America and what they stand for
and what they believe in so you know
perhaps the Pocahontas thing will stick
by her maybe she'll eventually have to
apologize for that maybe even her
Democratic opponents would attack her on
that but we'll see but I there are lots
of reasons she's not gonna win in 2020
and that is I might own one if if one at
all I love that pitch to Democrat voters
like a Hollywood pitcher okay listen
here's the nominee it's going to she's
going to have all of the intellect of a
desiccated old socialist who can't hold
a job but she'll be a humorless scold
and that been a friend that would
America why isn't that what middle
America is gonna vote for I don't think
so I wanna hear too bad yeah
gentlemen thank you for being here
excellent to have you both we will have
to get you back again and yeah Jason
Vincent thank you for being here and we
have to move on to mailbag thank you
okay so before we get into the mailbag
we have some business to clear up it's
the capitalism we and listen Christmas
shopping is very expensive I got to keep
the lights on I'm even considering
keeping Marshall employed for Christmas
so we'll have to get to another
excellent sponsor of ours stamps.com
now these days you can get anything you
want on demand I do not leave my chair I
do not want to spend more money than I
have to I get deals everywhere the
entire world is brought in through my
computer at my desk to me I make I
published a presidential endorsed
number-one bestseller
without moving anything I didn't even
move my fingers to type it was just all
blank
so as a millennial as a millennial and
anyone else who's living in the 21st
century you've got to check out
stamps.com anything you can do at the
post office you can do right now from
your desk with stamps calm you can buy
and print official US postage for any
letter or package using your own
computer and printer unlike the post
office stamps calm never closes when I
weigh I usually wake up about 3:00 p.m.
3:30 on days when I'm not do
the show I'll occasionally roll over and
do the show and at that point you know
the post office might be closed by the
time I roll out of bed stamps comm is
open 24/7 so I really like this
especially as a small business solution
in the old days they used to have these
giant clunky machines for postage and
they didn't work they would always break
they were expensive it's the 21st
century guys you don't need to you don't
need to go outside for anything have it
come to you take advantage of this it's
cheaper and you don't have to move as
much this is not a hard sell this is not
a horror to calculation to make so right
now if you use my code and you know what
my code is it my code is cough FA CoV f
EF e Co feffy it is it is a wonderful
adjective to describe wonderful services
like this you'll get a special offer
you'll get a four-week free trial that
includes postage and a digital scale I
am just offering you two things free
stuff and the ability to type in Kofa a
is a promo code because it's 2017 do not
wait go to stamps com and before you do
anything else don't click I know you're
gonna want to see all the deals and
stuff don't do it before you do anything
else click on the radio microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in what
you do these happen cough fac o v fe fe
stamps comm enter code fac o VF e f e
stamps calm never go to the post office
again i won't you sold me okay we have
got to get to the mailbag we have to
change your lives for the better so the
first question is from justin dear
patron saint of smug catholics i'm an
evangelical curious about Catholicism
but one made your point I don't
understand is the church's reverence for
the Virgin Mary
why is she considered so much greater
than other biblical figures that have
furthered the faith like st. Paul Moses
John the Baptist etc love to show Justin
thanks Justin that's a good question
consider the question I I don't mean to
to mock your question at all I get this
a lot and it's a serious question raised
by a lot of Christians but consider the
question you've just asked why do
Catholics venerate the mother of God
basically that's the answer that's the
end of it Mary is the mother of God
chosen
got to be the new Ark of the Covenant
right she is in her womb is God
conceived by the holy spirit out of
which he becomes man when when we recite
the Nicene Creed we kneel at that point
when we say Christ was conceived of the
Holy Spirit and he became a man in the
through the Virgin Mary that is that is
a miracle second only to the
resurrection the the physical and the
metaphysical uniting in Mary's womb but
the the other reason there there are
endless reasons as to why we ought to
venerate and adore Mary as the mother of
our Lord and and a mother that he has
given to us from the cross when he says
to the Apostle John behold Your Mother
my mother behold your son he gives her
to us as a mother but the other reason
is that there is this essential marriage
this beautiful marriage of grace and
Liberty that we find in the infancy
narratives right now I'm reading Jesus
of Nazareth the infancy narratives by
pope benedict xvi it is a wonderful
little book it reads like poetry I'm
reading it at the recommendation of the
supreme master of the multiverse Andrew
Clavin you have to read it for Advent it
is just so beautiful and savor it you
could read the whole thing in two hours
but you really read it slowly it's it's
really beautiful and there is this
essential combination of grace and
Liberty in Mary the Pope Benedict
describes it as all of the heavens
holding their breath when the angel
Gabriel comes down and says hail Mary
full of grace the Lord is with you
you've found favor with the Lord and
you're going to birth the son of God
you're going to he'll be born of you and
they all wait because she has to obey it
isn't purely great there isn't just
purely grace there it we're humans with
a free will and that freedom has to come
too so God comes down the mountain
offers everything to us but we have the
free will to turn away from God Mary
does not turn away from God she accepts
it her responses behold I am the servant
of the Lord let it be to me according to
your word and in that obedience we have
the salvation of the world so that's
just part of it there plenty of other
reasons
as well for why Mary is a pretty cool
lady and we all like her very much but
that's an introduction and I recommend I
recommend certainly googling it but
reading more about Mary listening to
studying Marian ology a little bit and
understanding how the veneration of Mary
has come about because I think there's a
Protestant misconception that it's this
weird pagan thing but certainly that
isn't the case Mary does sit right at
the inception of the human salvation
right at the heart of it it begins in
her womb all right I want to keep
changing your life for the better folks
but we got to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube if you are already a
subscriber thank you very much you keep
qoph fa in my mug now is a great time by
the way christmas time to subscribe to
the daily wire treat yourself it's been
a good year ferric offa year we've
gotten a lot of great stuff out of it or
you can give a gift subscription in any
case go to daily wire.com right now what
do you get you get me at the end or
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
yeah yeah yeah yeah you get no ads on
the website that's kind of cool but you
get this you get the leftist tears
tumblr we're talking a lot about
religion right now I it is not as sacred
as holy water it is not as sacred as
that but it is pretty sweet guy that's
yeah you know it's not it's it's below
but it's not that far below the leftist
years they're so delicious they're even
fairly comforting you can have them hot
or cold always salty and delicious we're
getting a nice batch from Nancy Pelosi
and John Conyers and Al Franken right
now obviously a Matt Lauer has given us
a case after case after case so make
sure that you can store them all and
have a nice vessel so you can enjoy them
by the Yule Log put a little muddled
spice into it go to daily wire.com right
now we'll be right back
[Music]
master Knowles this question comes from
tile master Knowles I was raised
Christian but am now agnostic as I have
had issues believing in Christ due to
the comparison of the new testament to
personification of astronomy I have seen
several comparisons that show that the
story of Christ is very similar to other
older religions and that used the story
as a way to explain the journey of the
Sun throughout the year and it's been
compelling enough to me to make me
question the New Testament but not God
himself
I ask you to debunk this I gladly will
PAL not to debunk Christianity or
Catholicism but rather that I can get a
clearer explanation as to why this
theory is false please assist me if you
will in coming closer to God with many
thanks Kyle
it would be my pleasure pal I also as an
agnostic atheist type for a decade of
beginning actually at my confirmation so
I can empathize with you this is a
little weird I think there's a kind of
logical error just in your thinking
about this you see or you've been told
you actually haven't seen similarities
and other religions but you've been told
by some Authority that there are many
similarities and the Christianity is
just a sort of copy of those religions
but so what Christianity is the greatest
story ever told by Christianity we know
that Christ is the logos of the universe
that breathed creation into existence so
it isn't surprising that there would be
echoes of the story the greatest story
ever told in throughout mythology
throughout all of mythology and
throughout history and in our own human
nature and in our own heart what I think
you're getting at though is that you
don't believe that Jesus existed as we
know him to exist you don't believe this
story of Jesus in the New Testament but
this puts you in a real minority of
people who have thought about this of
virtual minority of one I think what
you're getting at is something called
the christ myth the idea that the
historical Jesus if there even was one
is completely different than the guy we
know attested to in all of these
documents that we call the New Testament
the Christ myth theory are only
originated in the late 18th century so
within 300 years a little over 200 years
ago
one of the major theorists of this
Wisconsin
in Volney who believed a lot of other
nonsense too he also believed that
Abraham and Sarah were derived from
Hindu deities Brahma Saraswati and the
Christ is a version of Krishna he really
also thought that Christianity is just a
version of Syrian Egyptian and Persian
myths like that of Sol Invictus you kind
of hear this no serious scholar believes
this it it is rejected by scholars of
the New Testament and of 1st century
Rome and Palestine we know more about
Jesus of Nazareth and we know about
basically any person of that period with
a few except with the exception perhaps
of the other Prince of Peace who was
reigning in Rome Caesar Augustus the
that said so we know we know this
history about him I wouldn't really
question do the research yourself but I
don't think there's any reason to doubt
that so then the question is well how
come some religions seem similar to
Christianity a lot of atheists will tell
you well it's just a copy of that but
you don't really see it in all of these
myths that we're talking about whether
they are Persian myths or hidden Hindu
myths or whatever the the intersection
of the metaphysical with the physical
the encounter between heaven and earth
is categorically different in in many
mythologies you'll see the gods come
down and have sex with a mortal or
something and they give birth to
demigods or you'll see ancient monarchs
ancient kings suggesting that they are
part divine but that is fundamentally
different than the the virgin birth then
Christ being fully man and fully human
there's a theology to that where there
isn't really a theology to these older
myths there's a mythology and those are
categorically different things that said
I've studied a number of Hindu a lot of
Hindu religion and mythology there and
there are resemblances between say
Krishna and Christ or what-have-you but
this makes perfect sense because man is
born with an innate longing for God this
is this is one argument for God's
existence we're born with a thirst for
water and water exists to quench that
we're born with a hunger for food food
exists so that we can be full and we're
with the longing for God everywhere
every place on earth for all of history
we're born with a longing for God and
fairly similar conceptions of God and
therefore it seems perfectly reasonable
to me that there is a for many other
reasons as well
there is something to quench that thirst
there is something to satiate that
longing
so when you see resemblances between the
greatest story ever told between
Christianity and other mythologies a
little hint of true religion in
Norwegian mythology or sorry a Norse
mythology or Hinduism or this that or
the other thing that's a love that's
lovely and that makes perfect sense
because the God who created the entire
universe echoes throughout it and were
born with similar conceptions of him but
it requires theology not mythology to
figure out which which the right one is
and the right one is is Christianity I
am happy to tell you so you can return
to your faith good question
Gary oh this is another really serious
and esoteric question is cough f a
leftist ears or cough F a leftist ears
strained through a French press that
obviously that's the case that's the
only device through which they could be
strained and but by the way if you spill
your coffee F a leftist tears
you can always mop them up with the flag
of the French army so the France
pervades this entire process great
question from Christian hey Michael I've
always believed in God notice how much
God we get we get so many religious
questions I think because this
materialistic culture is unsatisfactory
and people are longing for that answer
as I did as a lot of people I know who
have gone through that stage back to the
question I've always believed in God I
never got into religion how do I know
which religion is Right Christianity
that's how that's the right one you want
to know there are a few that you could
think about you know there are two types
of religion that it would Bevin talks
about in a book I've mentioned a few
times symbolism and belief it's a book
that CS Lewis talks about in miracles
and he says there are two types of
religion there's theistic religion and
non-theistic religion so the religions
that believe in God like Christianity
Judaism sure a streon ISM and Islam and
religions that don't believe in God
so hinduism buddhism Shintoism other
religions you can't even really say east
and west so a serene ism is an Eastern
religion but it's theistic is LOM is
practically an Eastern religion but it's
theistic so those are two visions of the
world and it will require thinking about
theology to decide which of those is
correct I you know we talked to Leo
Severino today who did this book there
are a lot of great books the one that I
would always recommend is mere
christianity by CS Lewis Lewis is such
an incredible writer that he takes the
most impossibly complex things and
explains them for a three-year-old and
when I read it I had the theological
intelligence of a three-year-old so it
worked out very well
once you or conclude that God exists
which I think you will then you have to
deal with Christ so if the Hebrew
Messiah hasn't yet come then you're
probably a Jew if the Hebrew Messiah has
come you're probably a Christian if
Christ was a prophet if you're if you
believe in some of Christianity but you
reject the essence of it you reject the
most important claims of it then you
might fall into the category of Islam
which was founded after Mohammed spent
weeks with a heretical Christian monk in
Syria so it bears a lot of resemblance
to Christianity but it on essential
important matters it doesn't hold up
because
Mohammed founded his religion after
hanging out with a heretic for a very
long time so you you know what I think
about theology and Christ Christology
and I would I would explore down that
route and you might reach a different
conclusion than I have but I don't think
you will I think you'll reach that one
so good luck in your journey by the way
it isn't just books I should point out
andrew pleavin has a great video called
how to find God in 60 days he says just
act as though God exists and pray
praying is essential because we're not
just especially with Christianity we're
not just talking about a philosophy
we're not just talking about ideas that
you can learn when I talk about
Gnosticism we're talking about a
relationship with the God that created
you and saved you and that's very
personal that is a
you can't just get that in a book a book
can help you get there but that's a
relationship with a person so you'll
have to dig a little deeper than you
would researching history or Natural
Science or something
next question from Michael Michael could
you convince Ben and Jeremy that's Ben
Shapiro and Jeremy boring the god-king
at the Daily wire to let you change your
background to a wall of bookshelves
filled with your bestseller I feel like
Ben doesn't take you seriously enough
and because of your extreme humility
viewers are uh nor likely unaware of
your life's work Mike I appreciate it
man I appreciate you acknowledging my
magnum opus reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide which
sat number one on the bestseller list
for almost two weeks and was endorsed
personally but President Donald Trump on
Twitter it makes a great stocking
stuffer by the way it is true you know
great works of genius or very often not
recognized during the author's lifetime
they might be underappreciated during
the author's lifetime but as I wrote in
the first pages in the preface two
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide quoting Thucydides I
have written my work not as an essay to
win the applause of the moment but as a
possession for all time so perhaps if it
can't if it can't be constantly
displayed for this popular audience it
will reach an esoteric elite audience
now and for generations to come thank
you for appreciating true scholarship
from Cliff swarthy Mike that is my real
name by the way what do you think we
would be talking about right now if
Hillary had won for example instead of a
battle about anthem kneeling the
conversation we'd be out changing the
name of Redskins or instead of North
Korea it'd be a war on gun owners any
ideas thanks Clifford the Great yes two
things on this and it's one where
Trump's critics on the right don't give
him enough credit because all they see
first of all there's all the great stuff
Trump is done but there are some things
that Trump has done that perhaps we
don't all agree with might have gone too
far
might have been counterproductive some
of them might have been flat-out bad
ideas the the handling of James Comey
seems to be the the worst decision of
his presidency so far because it led to
this Muller investigation which is a big
cloud hanging over the administration
there are two sides of this one what
would we be talking about on the
cultural conversation you're right we'd
be talking about bathrooms we'd be
talking about gender bathrooms you know
the the issue that affects seven people
in the entire country that would
dominate the national conversation
because it's a way of getting the left's
arguments and premises in by the back
door
taking compassion for a handful of
people and squeezing in all of their
relativism and their vision of politics
as groups of people just battling each
other for interests rather than as a
civil discourse in a United body politic
so that would be the cultural
conversation but as a matter of policy
it would be horrible I'm glad that I
can't be profane in my language on this
show because I there are so many words I
could use to explain how awful it would
be we would have Hillary Clinton
campaigned on damaging if not outright
undercutting the first and second
amendment she campaigned there were
separate pages on her website about this
the Citizens United decision which
citizens united was overturned or rather
they're citizens united was ruled and
overturned campaign finance laws mccain
feingold because there were a violation
of the first amendment the question was
can you criticize Hillary Clinton a few
weeks before an election was centered
around Hillary so now we have our robust
First Amendment which is the under
attack from all corners of the left and
the second amendment that if we had that
Supreme Court justice if we had a lefty
replace Antonin Scalia we would have
awful decisions that seriously
threatened your liberty and mine coming
down the pike to say nothing of
legislation to say nothing we might have
been able to obstruct a little bit but
it's hard to predict these things so on
both sides on the real policy side and
on the cultural conversation things are
looking a lot better not even because
Trump is in I think that's also true but
just because Hillary isn't things are so
much better and that's great christmas
came early i guess from ian
i've never had a problem seeing divine
providence in other situations like when
you and Clavin were talking about the
pilgrims in my own life however i'm not
as good at seeing it as you can imagine
this leads me to feel abandoned by God
do you
have any advice on how I can start to
see him in my own life thanks Ian
yeah yes I can it's an evil generation
that looks for signs and wonders don't
forget that so I think the way to see
him is to stop looking at you it's to
stop looking at your own life and stop
looking inward at yourself and look at
him the evidence of him is all around
you you know that it's all around you
because you see it everywhere else you
don't go looking for signs and wonders
it isn't a good thing I mean I you'll
see them all the time once it clicks in
you will see it in every little
seemingly ridiculous coincidence in your
life father George rut ler has an
excellent book on apparently random
coincidences it's called coincidentally
it's very enjoyable very funny and it
does make a sort of serious point about
Providence the quote he uses on the
cover is from Alexander Pope's essay on
man while nature has been art unknown to
thee all chance Direction which thou
canst not see it seems to me that you
are not seeing that direction in your
own life if you can see it when you look
elsewhere and you can't see it when you
look at yourself then I would keep
looking elsewhere keep looking forward
keep doing you kid just do the right
thing you know keep your head down and
live your life and if you don't harp on
your own feelings of abandonment by God
or how God wrong dia or how anybody else
wrongs you were all the problems in your
life if you just keep doing what you can
do remember
suffering is is not immoral it's morally
neutral it's how we react to suffering
that is moral we can either react to
suffering in a good way or we can react
to the suffering in a sinful way we get
how to react to it with perseverance and
kissing it up to God as we used to say
or you can react to it and say woe is me
and life is terrible and why does
everyone have it so much better than me
one of those is a good moral choice one
of those is a bad moral choice so keep
your eyes ahead and look out for God I
think that you'll find him and pray
that's our entire show today a very
godly show I guess it's because
christmas came early I guess that's why
that's it for it talk about Providence
folks ok that's our show for the week
but don't forget this weekend you'll get
another Kingdom you'll be able to sit
save yourself from the chaos at the
clayvin last weekend
go to iTunes stitcher google play
wherever great narrative podcasts about
Hollywood schlubs who fall into fantasy
worlds with bloody daggers and dead
damsels written by conservative people
who also work in the arts and perform by
them to wherever those are downloaded
you can get another Kingdom and survive
the clayvin this weekend until Monday
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show we will see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
Haig
supervising producer Mathis clever our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex's and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jessa alvera the Michael Nolt show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2017